[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Régine raleège des
propositions pour répondre à l'urgences
des quartiers prioritaires elles ont été
remises cette semaine à Emmanuel Macron
par l'Association des Maires ville et
banlieude- France oui et ce rapport
propose 10 mesures d'urgence notamment
sur l'éducation l'emploi la sécurité à
titre d'exemple l'insertion
professionnelle par le sport ou encore
le retour des contrats aidés associatifs
et publics l'objectif c'est d'apporter
des solutions au problèmes récurrent que
rencontrent les quartiers populaires et
parmi les membres de l'association ayant
remis ce rapport au chef de l'État se
trouvait Catherine Arnou maire de la
ville de Chantelou lévges et
vice-présidente de l'association un
comité interministériel des villes
devrait d'ailleurs se tenir à chantlou
lévg ce vendredi 27 octobre pour donner
suite à ses propositions c'est une
première en une semaine et j'ai envie de
dire heureusement pas d'évacuation ce
mardi pour le château de Versailles et
des évacuations d'ailleurs qui ne sont
pas sans conséquence entre 100 et 150000
€ c'est le préjudice estimé pour chaque
évacuation du château de Versailles
selon l'avocat du site yvinois depuis le
14 octobre le domaine a dû être évacué à
Sep reprises en raison de fausses
alertes à la bombe ces montants
correspondent notamment au billets
remboursés et à la baisse de
fréquentation de certains visiteurs un
mot de sport et du basket un camp de
basket à destination des jeun est
organisé depuis ce lundi et ce jusqu'à
ce samedi au Hoops corner de carrière
soissie il a été imaginé par michaell
Mokongo ancien basketteur professionnel
qui a joué en fin de carrière à l'ESC
trappp Saint-Quentin en Yveline au
programme des exercices le matin et
l'après-midi avec différents coachs et
préparateurs on écoute Michel Mokongo au
micro de tv78 le concept de ce camp
c'est d'essayer de voilà de développer
la région parce que nous avons beaucoup
de clubs de basketball et une population
qui est assez jeune l'idée c'est c'est
voilà d'essayer de d'aider les jeunes
qui ont vraiment besoin de se développer
techniquement sur le basketball et aussi
de de de de répertorier un petit peu
leur faiblesse et d'avoir un
accompagnement ce que j'appelle XXL
autour de voilà tout ce qui est
préparateur physique tout ce qui est
coach mental tout ce qui est docteur
tout ce qui est physiothérapeute tout ce
qui est nutritionniste tout ce qui est
euh vraiment autour du basketball autour
de la communauté
sportive et si vous voulez vous aussi
vous inscrire il reste encore des places
vous pouvez contacter l'organisateur via
le site internet qui s'affiche à l'écran
et d'ailleurs en parlant d'événement la
murder Pary le jeu de rôle grand ur
nature du département des ivelines est
annulé en raison de l'alerte urgence
attentat il devait se tenir à l'ancien
domaine du de Madame elliisabeth le 28
octobre prochain les équipes de
l'événement vous invitent à suivre leur
programmation sur le site mysteries Hunt
pour connaître le cadre le la nouvelle
date de report merci Régine pour toutes
ces actualités et comme d'habitude si
vous aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une information dans les
Eveline qui vous fait réagir et
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news